everybody what's going on blade here I'm
very very excited to welcome Camilla
Luddington to twitch that's right the
voice of Lara Croft
and also on Grey's Anatomy ABC Thursday
night today uh and I thought it would be
super fun to have you here to play a
little bit of Tomb Raider or watch me
play as what you kill that's right so we
get some sweet Croft on cross so how
much of this game have you seen a lot of
this game I've seen that game with the
entire way the entire way through oh my
god and I have to watch in the very
early days and they had a speak and is
that true yeah that's amazing
yeah that they do things to just to
throw you off did they also try to scare
you yeah Jesus Christ I know I know I
know exactly no you did motion-capture
this game I heard took three years how
possibly did that take so you obviously
stay in shape I mean you stay in shape
anyway but for three whole years they
didn't hang you upside down so this is
you acting this is me acting stood up
yes that's all I know what you need to
do right yeah that will help me out then
help me yeah so you have to push that
thing and it sets on fire so do they
give you it isn't it is it awkward to be
in a room or someone were you're doing
this and someone's like more struggling
[Laughter]
what are some of what are some of your
favorite motions that were captured in
this game oh yeah asked me to drown
let's hear it can you do because I
actually did there's water do you want
one oh I'll just pour water on you
like this much Oh what are they so what
do they do for what did they stab you in
the side look I don't even have a kidney
I'm missing a kid no this is me just
being but you didn't know was obviously
gonna look like this no you were just
hoping that they know you know what they
kind of show you when you're when you're
before we do a scene they kind of show
me what the area looks like obviously I
don't know what she looks like in the
scene yet right right exactly I do know
the surroundings okay oh I see so
they're like you're in I had the image
of how horrifying that was my god oh
yeah in case I was imagining something
like you know so they showed you
drawings and things like that
yeah where was the game kind of complete
at that point there it wasn't complete
but there were moments where they were a
little bit ahead production really was
very similar looking to this on their
laptops Wow yeah that's amazing and then
so and so what are you what are some of
your favorite moments in this game that
were the most fun to would you get
double guns oh yeah of course
spoiler alert yeah by the way if you
haven't played this game already what's
wrong with you play this game yeah geez
all right I think we have some fan
questions Ruthie let's let's let's do
some fan questions so if you get exactly
but you have to choose one I think love
child oh god that's awful you actually
came up with an answer that's worse than
any of us
I don't even that's nightmares
nightmares nightmares alright another
fan question that's right
no I can't think of anything I used to
think of whistling oh you mean something
that every dog check this out my dog
destiny
I can't even whistle no I can't whistle
all right I'm a dog I can't be trusted
with it and I can barely trust myself no
you know what I do have though an
apartment full of crickets not my choice
they just come in yeah the Pied Piper of
crickets that's how I get ladies at the
bar Pied Piper of crickets fair enough
all right no question that's shoe why
don't you play a doctor you've done I
think the pact - I did a horror movie I
played a Sperry with supernatural powers
on Tru Blood awesome I don't even care
if I'm an extra and you just like see me
require the camera that's enough you
just want to be in Giratina and just
maybe if I just touch Khaleesi
just get some that creepy the dragon
mother pixie dust amazing um no wait a
second let me ask you a question so you
a reamer hasn't you've started doing
voice work in motion capture for the new
rise of the Tomb Raider okay now I would
love to get a team Coco exclusive can
you give us a noise from the new one
noise ready this is an exclusive guys
noise from the rise of the Tomb Raider
go amazing you heard it here first
and what about what about emotion let's
get a gonna get emotion emotion from the
new one ready here we go here's a motion
from the new rise the Tomb Raider
prepare yourselves if you're wearing
socks take them off because they're
about to be knocked off ready yes I love
it
I that was boilers genies spoilers I
don't know if you've got dirt on you
is that a major plot point that is very
important there's there's dirt now we
know there's dirt I don't know why you
would even want to play the new don't
even bother buying it that's ridiculous
all right let's add one more fan
question yes that would be awesome
who would would you I don't uh well I've
got kind of hairy legs I don't want to
go into it these old tree trunks
shouldn't be seen I don't think they
have a camera that could really fill me
maybe I max max 3d I do a lot of squats
I don't want to get into it yeah it's
pretty intense
I'd be nc-17 so I keep going on about my
legs or is it credible and and doing
active you have you done an action
what's the pack to actioning the game
with is action and did you before you
did motion cam mocap for the game did
you have to take martial arts training
did you have to do any kind of no no no
so I got thrown into it and I love it if
you wait like 400 pounds and you're like
well I'm gonna feel Eric Roth yeah I
better start losing some weight yeah I'm
gonna have to wear a bow cap soon
they're very particular actually like
sighs for some reason I would just even
like your highest five six
it was like we had stuff like that and I
did in my own dish if I had to like
Brandon jump so clearly I didn't -
terrible that's correct
I was in no way - Rainer she was there I
mean this is a dumb question but was
there like some kind of like obstacle
like what do you mean run and jump in or
hurt are you just doing this in a room
like the valley yeah I had webcam set up
I don't want to go into it let's cut to
that footage now no our yeah they just
say run across the room and then like
pretend it's so awkward and you thought
they were embarrassing when you were
auditioning you thought it was gonna be
from this game called your encrypted or
something I didn't even know that's
that's crazy oh good job guys wait yeah
it's not Lara it's Sarah yeah exactly
yeah it's Sarah saw oh thank you yes I
played this yeah I played this let's
just say a few times
whoa but look at that can you give us a
good death shriek give us a good does
she like really or just like a you know
I did this to Conan and you said it
sound like I was eating a burrito Wow
you've never seen him eat a burrito yeah
this person looks just what we're
dealing with Conan just realized you're
not the we're a guy's life is he's
drinking some weird green shake
yesterday I'm pretty sure he's not it's
like some kind of lizard man just pulls
masks all right well before before you
go did you did you get to kick someone
in the face when you did that no no I
got smashed
we're trying to see yourself getting
murdered it's a lot see it when
sometimes if you ever video is that true
you're in traffic you can wait five more
minutes all right before we go it's an
okay if I have you now when I was
playing this game when I play this game
I should say there are freezes that I
wish Lara would say that she kind of
never says throughout the game but I I
wish while playing she was a do you mind
reading a couple of these phrases there
we go yeah now just think about these
for maybe the next Tomb Raider game ok
Rehan kind of as sexy as possible all
right you ready ok good oh yeah that's
right let's just stay in my god a 6 you
clearly aren't eating the right kind of
pizza combinational no they're delicious
ooh does that guy have visible ab
muscles gross
yeah you don't want a six-pack but he
does love Jonah and the game what makes
sense it makes sense tell me more about
your Batman fan fiction I find it
fascinating that one might be a little
more revealing about myself yeah I might
have thrown my hand a little bit who's
that sexy guy clutching that 50 hook a
Haven controller
Lara likey no maybe the Easter Egg
Easter
[Music]
I'm oh I'm embarrassed okay don't listen
I think having gray hair and a brown
boot really is sexy yeah thank you we
can keep that one in ten ten out of ten
yes Tomb Raider put it in the next game
guys all right Camilla Luddington thank
you so much fantastic you can follow
Camila Twitter at Camilla Luddington
yeah and on Instagram official Camilla
Luddington and game Grey's Anatomy
Thursdays at 8:00 on ABC and look for
rise of the Tomb Raider coming out next
holiday see you next holiday season I
love it thank you so much Camilla and
stay tuned for more great video gameplay
you